I'm so busy because I run my own theater
school hence why I never have time to
cook I'd really like to learn to cook
something that's fast obviously it
doesn't take too much preparation time
something that's quick some healthy
something it's not too complicated which
will get my confidence up a bit I think
it's really important to be able to cook
especially you and I've got a husband a
little baby although I'm very
embarrassed that I can't actually okay
now why can't you cook few reasons
really mostly because my mum can't cook
really baby huh I'm totally blaming her
yeah but you must be able to do
absolutely these lots of simple things
surely I can do toast toast
Betty black Betty Betty called dear I
did my solution is a fast food fix but
real fast food pasta fresh tiger telly
and something that is not too
complicated and we could use dried
linguini or spaghetti but this is a
fresh tagliatelle the secret is of
course cooking the pasta very very
simply and boiling water salted boiling
water touch of olive oil in there and
they can mix all these things in there
things like marinated artichoke hearts
and you know the olives the smoked
pancetta great for as the dish is easy
to fry and really full of flavor these
general things should be in your store
cupboard you know I'm going to teach
Rachel a simple pasta dish that you can
cook in 10 minutes flat
I need some fresh crab some fresh chili
some lemon juice and passing through
there and just mix it up that's what is
the hardest thing of course just cooking
the pasta yep a than that everything
else is double exposure Hey first thing
we do is put on a pan of water put the
water in good
so take the pot okay chopping border
here please
yeah boys last time you chocolate chili
yeah never good okay get the chili we
just rub it together like that okay and
what that does it loosens all the little
seeds in the center what you taking the
top off slide down the center like that
right okay and then just open up with
your fingers look just push all the way
down and all that does it gets rid of
the seeds and the seeds are actually
hotter than the chili that's what
worries me about chilies yeah well I'm
acting in my eyes yeah yeah most
important thing now is cause by the time
you finished chopping it okay just wash
your hands very very quickly to get the
chili just take nice small slices there
but three ingredients so far
pasta crab and chili no decent parsley
yep and it's flat leaf parsley so helps
us cut down the strength of chili and
just make it a lot more flavor some
waters come out to the ball nice handful
of pasta yeah into the water place
that's the other thing I never know how
much passes he can toss with a bowl that
you go to serve in you get your bowl
yep okay you look there okay now that
looks a nice portion yeah yeah
so spoonful the change in there yep good
cut me in good excellent do something
away from the stove and you look like
you're really nervous about
okay look like you're in control of it
yes
how can you handle 320 kids it's cooking
that's cool cooking
I don't you just squeeze some fresh
lemon juice in there fresh parsley over
there
okay nice lift off one strand we want
what we're looking for
it's a bit of a bite in there just about
right into your pasta now it's really
important to get all that crab meat
mixed into it now mix that up okay but
look you're not doing it well get your
spoon in there again I want you to mix
all that in there like that okay all of
it in there together
yep quicker than a microwave meal
without a doubt yeah - really nice balls
just a smell yes gorgeous so that's a
meal for two in less than 10 minutes I
can't believe you've done this
Wow not too much help no it helps me the
boss right James happy very happy yes
really nice don't need to be scared of
something
stick to something really simple yeah I
just climbed the ladder with it yeah we
use crap yeah next time maybe problems
next time brush you buy tomatoes and you
know just maybe think about it during
the day and pick up the stuff on the way
yeah yeah
thank you 840 miles an hour